THE MEANING OF THE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE.
.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED. AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL RECALL ROLE WE DON'T
CALDERON. CARRILLO CALDERON
THOUGH WE HAVE WARM LITTLE
RUSTY.
THE FIRST ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HEARING
OF THE YEAR.
.
NOT INCLUDING THE JOINT
COMMITTEE THAT WE HAD A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. BEFORE WE BEGIN I
HAVE A HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT
TO MAKE A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SIX
CARILLO HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO BE HEARD. AT
OUR HEARING TODAY.
AND I THINK.
IT WILL BE HEARD FIRST AT OUR
HEARING TODAY.
SOURCE ON THE NUMBER CARILLO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO COME PRESENT YOUR
BILL
.
GOOD MORNING MORNING.
THE THING ON ERICA.
GOOD MORNING UP MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM HERE TO PERCENT AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIXTH A BILL TO
HELP CONDUCT SPECIAL ELECTIONS
FAIRLY. ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THE RECENT US US BASE OF
VACANCY.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT ANY
VACANCY IN THE ASSEMBLY SENATE
OR CONGRESSIONAL SEAT BE FILLED
BY A SPECIAL PRIMARY ELECTION.
AND IF NEEDED A SPECIAL GENERAL
ELECTION IT CURRENTLY FALLS ON
OUR COUNTIES TO PAY ALL EXPENSES
TO PREPARE FOR AND CONDUCT THE
SPECIAL ELECTIONS. THE STATE
RARELY PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THESE
ELECTIONS AND A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SIX WILL TAKE THE FIRST
STEP IN ADDRESSING THESE
CONCERNS BY LIFTING THE COSTLY
BURDEN. OF STATE AND FEDERAL
SPECIAL ELECTIONS AND SHIFTING
THEM TO THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY URBAN
AND RURAL COUNTIES ACROSS OUR
STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. SUPPORT AND AB. AT
EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTY SIX WITH ME
HERE TO TESTIFY IS THE LOGIN THE
REGISTER RECORD COUNTY CLERK
FROM LA COUNTY.
MORNING GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN BERMAN MEMBERS
COMMITTEE THINK YOU CAPTAIN
SPEAK AND BE IN LOVE AND I'M
REGISTER RECORDER COUNTY CLERK
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
MUST SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A QUICK
SELECTION OFFICIALS WHO ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WHEN I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND FOR A
TIME FOR.
BRING AWARENESS TO INITIATIVE
THAT WE WOULD THINK ABOUT LA
COUNTY ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
THAT IS THE THE COST OF SPECIAL
VACANCY ELECTIONS IN LA COUNTY.
AS I'VE PROVIDED ON THE.
ATTACHED TO MY TESTIMONY WE HAVE
CONDUCTED. IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
FIFTEEN SPECIAL ELECTIONS FROM
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND NOW NINE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS.
IN THIS YEAR ALONE ALREADY
WE'RE JUST A FEW MONTHS INTO
INTO THE YEAR AND SO THAT THE
CUMULATIVE COST OF THAT FOR THAT
LA COUNTY HAS MORNING.
.
APPROACHES OR AN AND MAY EXCEED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S MONEY THAT THAT GETS
PULLED AWAY FROM. OTHER COUNTY
SERVICES AND PRIORITIES.
IT'S IT'S AND BUDGETED MONEY
AND IT ALSO PULLS AWAY FROM
ELECTIONS PERSPECTIVE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED TO BE WORKING ON
THE MODERNIZATION OF OUR VOTING
SYSTEMS AND DOING VOTER OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION.
I'M SO WE KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST HAS
PROVIDED SOME REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SPECIAL ELECTION COSTS. AND
WHILE THAT WAS ALL THAT WAS
BETTER THAN THE SITUATION TODAY
EVEN THE PREVIOUS MODEL WAS
BASED ON A FORMULA THAT DID NOT
COVER THE FULL ACTUAL COST OF
CONDUCTING THOSE ELECTIONS ON
SO.
I WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND ASK YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
YOUR SUPPORT AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIR CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF RIVERSIDE SANTA
CLARA SANTA CRUZ VENTURA AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU.
JUST GOOGLE LOW HERE ARE GOOD
MORNING JOHN THE CLAY ABOUT FOR
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AWESOME
SUPPORT OUR.
LAST TO SPECIAL ACTIONS BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT QUITE ON THE SKILLED
LA BUT I TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. THANK YOU.
NOW BACK TO BACK THEN. AYE TRACY
SELL THEM ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN PART SUPPORT THEY
GIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
AND IT LOOKS THEY LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO LET'S TAKE A
QUICK BREAK TO ESTABLISH A.
WARM.
AND CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN HERE.
BERMAN HERE HARPER PRESENT.
HARPER HERE CALDERON. CALDERON
CARRILLO.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
WEBER.
WEBER HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COLLEGE. BUT YOUR HARPER.
I WANNA QUESTIONS FOR THE
AVERAGE FOR OUR FIGHT COULD ASK
ON.
MIKE'S THINGS THAT WERE COMING
UP ON THE LINING THE.
THE LOCAL ELECTIONS WITH THE.
WITH THE STATE ELECTIONS WHAT
IS THE TIMELINE ON THAT.
THAT'S CORRECT THOUGH I AM THE
PERSON A BILL FOR FIFTEEN THAT
PASSED.
TWO YEARS AGO AND THE THE CITIES
AND LOCAL DISTRICTS HAVE
ENTAILED TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
ALIGN WITH THE AT THE STATE
ELECTION CYCLE MOST CITIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS IN LA COUNTY
HAVE ALREADY.
I'M TAKEN THAT THE PROCEDURAL
PASSED THE RESOLUTIONS TO DO
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THOSE WILL.
MANY OF US LIKELY START TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND AND THE MAJORITY OF
THEM WILL ALREADY BE DONE BY
TWENTY TWENTY.
THANK YOU
BUT JUST A BRIEF COMMENT DOES
WHAT ONE OF THINGS THAT I'VE
OBSERVED OVER LAST A COUPLE OF
DECADES IS THAT.
BEFORE THE MOST RECENT SPATE OF.
OF RESIGNATIONS IN SUCH
TYPICALLY A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
VACANCIES IN THE LEAD STATE
LEGISLATURE WERE OFTEN BECAUSE
THE LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS WOULD RUN. FOR SIMPLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN LOS ANGELES
RUN FOR CITY COUNCIL BECAUSE THE
STAGGERED ELECTIONS IT OFTEN
BECAUSE VACANCY BUT WITH THAT.
WILL HAVE PROBABLY REDUCED POOL
I THINK OF.
OF FOLKS WERE THE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS I DO INDEED HAPPEN.
WHETHER IT'S BY DEATH WHETHER
ESPY RESIGNATION WHETHER SPOT
FOR OTHER MEANS. I'M A VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SPECIAL
ELECTION AS THE A DECIDER OF.
WHO GETS?
TO SUCCEED IN ANY VACANCY
SITUATION RATHER THAN SOME KIND
OF APPOINTMENT UP OR OTHER
SYSTEM SO I'M VERY VERY HAPPY.
TO SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM A
LOS ANGELES INTRODUCED SIDE THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S A LONG TIME
COMING IT'S WHAT WE USED TO DO.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
STATE USE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
COSTS.
A LOT OF ITS ELECTION SYSTEMS
BUT THE STATE START CUTTING
CORNERS BY ITS SOME POINT. I IN
I THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP BUT TOWARDS THE
RESTORATION OF THE DEMOCRACY IN
THE STATE. AYE SO I IS SOMETHING
I'VE TALKED ABOUT A WHILE IF I'M
NOT ALREADY I'D LOVE TO BE
INCLUDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND I
WILL MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISS HARPER.
AND I HAVE A SECOND.
MOTION BY MISTER HARPER SIGMA
MISTER CALDERON.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
WITH THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
WITH CAUGHT THERE AND THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALSO BEING A
CLOTH AROUND THIS BILL. MISTER
LOGAN PASSED OUT THIS THAT FACT
SHEET THAT'LL JUST A SHOW YOU ON
THE BACKSIDE ALL THE SPECIAL
ELECTION THAT LA COUNTY. HAS
ENCOUNTERED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WHICH OF WILL AMOUNT TO
UP TO NOW THE NINE UPCOMING
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
LA COUNTY SO WE CAN DEFINITELY
USE TO HELP BUT I THINK THAT
ONLY FRAWLEY COUNTY BUT. ACROSS
THE STATE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO.
AND AND MISTER LOGAN. THE STATE
USED TO REMEMBER AS A VICE CHAIR
HARPER SAID THE STATE.
USED TO REIMBURSE COUNTIES FOR
THE CASA SPECIAL ELECTIONS HELD
TO FILL VACANCIES IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND IN CONGRESS.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
THE UNEXPECTED COSTS OF THE
SPECIAL ELECTIONS CAN BE A BIG
STRAIN ON COUNTY BUDGETS.
IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE'S RESUME
THAT PRACTICE AND CONTRIBUTE
TOWARD THE COST OF CONDUCTING
ELECTIONS THAT BENEFIT THE STATE
SOME HAPPY.
TO GET TO BE A CO AUTHOR THE
SPELLING ALSO RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT.
I WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE A COLLARED VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE HARPER AYE AYE HARPER AYE
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW.
LOW I'VE MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SO.
EYES ARE FIVE NEWSER ZERO WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BUT.
THE BILL IS OUT.
YEAH.
THANK YOU AND THANKS.
THEN AND NEXT UP.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS FROM MR LOW.
SUMMER LOW WHICH BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT FIRST.
YOUR YOUR PREFERENCES MISTER
BONTA PRESENTING WITH YOU SIR ON
ON.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE.
THEN THEN PLEASE PICK WHATEVER
BILL YOU'D PREFER.
PREFERABLY THE EASIER ONE OF THE
TWO.
ABILITY.
YES THEY ARE.
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF.
ALLOW ME THEN TO PRESENT A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN.
THE PROHIBITION OF PAYMENTS PER
SIGNATURE.
AB NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN WILL
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
INITIATIVE PROCESS BY
ELIMINATING.
THE BILL THE OF SIGNATURE
GATHERS TO SEE PAYMENT PER
SIGNATURE.
THE NEED TO COLLECT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SIGNATURES WITHIN
THE LIMITED TIME FOR HAS
RESULTED IN THE CREATION OF.
PETITION MANAGEMENT FIRMS WHICH
GOES AGAINST THE FUNDAMENTAL.
BASIS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
AT THIS BILL WILL HELP MAINTAIN
THAT WE CONTINUE TO.
INVEST IN THE SPIRIT OF OUR.
DIRECT DEMOCRACY PROCESS AND TO
BE CLEAR OF THIS BILL SIMPLY.
A ALLOWS THAT SIGNATURE
GATHERERS CAN BE PAID HOURLY OR
BY STIPEND BY STIPEND RATHER
THAN JUST
SIMPLY.
ENCOURAGING THAT OF THE
SIGNATURE THEMSELVES.
AT TODAY WITH ME IS.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
YOU'RE CAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST MAY CONSUMERS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I'M YOU
KNOW THE INITIATIVE PROCESS WITH
CREATED BY THE PEOPLE FOR THE
PEOPLE AND IT WAS THE AWAY FORCE
REGULAR CITIZENS TO AFFECT
CHANGE IF THEY FELT LIKE THERE
LAWMAKERS WORK DOING IT FOR
THEM.
AND AT THE TIME SIGNATURE
GATHERING WAS ALMOST UNIVERSALLY
UNPAID COMPLETELY. AND SO REALLY
YOU KNOW THIS THIS MEASURE SEEKS
TO RESTORE HOW THE PROCESS WAS
INTENDED AND THE LACK OF
QUALIFYING A BALLOT MEASURE IN
THE PAST WAS JUST A SIGN THAT
THIS. MAYBE DIDN'T HAVE THE
GRASSROOTS SUPPORT NEEDED TO
EFFECT THATCHANGE SO WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO DO HERE IS JUST
GET BACK TO THE ORIGINAL INTENT
OF THAT CALIFORNIA'S BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
WERE NOT ELIMINATING PAYMENT
FOR SIGNATURE GATHERING
COMPLETELY AS THE AUTHOR STATED
JUST REALLY TRYING TO. RESTORE
FAIRNESS INTO THE PROCESS AND
AND SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I INGRAM OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL
WE'VE SHARED OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN SOME
LANGUAGE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME'S
LURKER TEST NAME HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY WHILE WE BELIEVE IN
UPHOLDING THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS. THIS BILL
WILL DENY CALIFORNIANS THE RIGHT
TO DIRECT DEMOCRACY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAD SOME ISSUES WITH AND
FEELING THAT THE SIGNATURE
GATHERERS WERE LITTLE TOO
AGGRESSIVE. HOW AND IT APPEARS
THAT THE GOAL OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN IS ALSO TO ADDRESS
VOTER REGISTRATION FRAUD HOWEVER
THIS BILL WILL NOT REMEDY THOSE
ISSUES WALTZ A WORTHY GOAL AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN? WILL HAVE
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
LIMITING THE PUBLIC'S
PARTICIPATION AND ABOUT PROCESS.
IN BY OUTLINE PAYMENT FOR
SIGNATURE ON A PER SIGNATURE
BASIS THIS BILL WILL BE MOM
CREATE A PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
PROCESS WHEREBY MAKING IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR RECALLS AND
INITIATIVES AND POTENTIALLY ON
AND I'M AND. IMPOSSIBLE TO DO A
REFERENDUM IN ADDITION THERE'S
NO COMPELLING EVIDENCE THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY RAMPANT FRAUD
WITH THIS PAYMENT PROCESS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S ELECTION
FRAUD INVESTIGATION UNIT OPENED
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY CASES OVER
A DECADE AND A HALF FROM
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO TWO
THOUSAND TEN. WITH THAT THERE
WERE ONLY THIRTY THREE
CONVICTIONS THERE ARE ALSO
HUNDREDS OF INITIATIVES PLACED
ON BALLOTS REQUIRING MILLIONS OF
SIGNATURES SO FOR OVER A DECADE
HALF THEIR ONLY THIRTY THREE
CONVICTIONS WITH A MILLION
SIGNATURE WITH MILLIONS OF
SIGNATURES REQUIRED. THE CURRENT
PROCESS IS A CHECK AND BALANCE
ON GOVERNMENT BY MAKING IT
HARDER TO QUALIFY BALLOT
MEASURES YOU ARE DENYING
CALIFORNIANS OPPORTUNITY EXPRESS
GRIEVANCES DIRECTLY WITH THEIR
GOVERNMENT THROUGH INITIATIVE.
MET AND BALLOTS AND REFERENDUMS
WE UNDERSTAND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GOALS AND WHILE WE AT
WHILE WE BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
WELL INTENTIONED W LOOK FORWARD
TO FINDING ALTERNATIVE METHOD TO
GET TO THOSE SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING DAVID WOLF WITH THAT
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
TAVY NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN TODAY.
MEMBERS IT'S WORTH NOTING FIRST
OF ALL THAT THE SAME BILL WAS
TRIED IN TWENTY ELEVEN.
BY SENATOR CORBETT AND WAS
VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND YOU
HAVE THE EXACT SAME BILL IS
BEFORE US TODAY IS HOW WE JUST
THROW THAT OUT IS POINT NUMBER
ONE. I'M.
LISTEN MEMBERS IS THERE AN
OVERRELIANCE ON PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS AND OUR INITIATIVE
PROCESS.
PERHAPS
RIGHT DO WE DO WE WISH THAT
THERE WAS LESS RELIANCE ON PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERERS TO QUALIFY
INITIATIVES SURE.
BUT THERE'S CERTAIN WAYS TO GO
ABOUT DOING THAT RIGHT WE CAN.
FOR EXAMPLE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I NOTE IN OUR LETTER
WE CAN INCREASED THE AMOUNT OF
TIME YOU TO GATHER SIGNATURES.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT WE CAN GO
OUT AND TARGET OUR MEMBERS WITH
PETITIONS WITH TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. AND WE CAN DO THAT AND WE
DON'T NEED PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS OR AT LEAST A
DECREASED ALLIANCE ON THE
QUALIFY INITIATIVES THAT WOULD
BE GREAT BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T
DO THAT.
THIS BILL HAS MAJOR AND MASSIVE
FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUES.
.
WE SHOULDN'T BE PUNISHING PEOPLE
WHO ENGAGE IN A FREE MARKET
CONTRACT TO ENGAGE IN A GOOD.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE OUT THERE
GATHERING SIGNATURES IN BEING
PAID FOR THAT WHAT'S THE PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
AND YOU KNOW TO QUALIFY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT RIGHT
NOW TO BE SAFE YOU LETTER WE
NEED TO GATHER A MILLION
SIGNATURES HOW WILL THAT HAPPEN.
WITHOUT PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SIX MONTHS
NEEDED THE QUALIFYING INITIATIVE
THERE ARE WAYS TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND DECREASE OUR
ALLIANCE UNPAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
THE WAY TO DO IT AND ASK FOR
ANOTHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE OPENING UP THE
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THEY HAVE.
MISS HARPER.
HELLO.
POINTED OUT DOWN.
IT IS HAVE PREVIOUSLY POINTED
OUT TO US.
GOVERNOR BROWN NOT VETOED A BILL
ON MUCH LIKE THIS JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO HE STATED THE BILL WAS
FLAWED BECAUSE IT WOULD
EFFECTIVELY PROHIBIT
ORGANIZATIONS FROM SETTING
TARGETS OR QUOTAS. UP FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE A.
THEY HIRE AYE TO GATHER
SIGNATURES THEREBY MAKING THE
PRODUCTIVITY.
GOALS A CRIME I IN THAT WOULD
INDEED DRIVE UP THE COST OF
CIRCLING BALLOT MEASURES THERE
BY FAVORING THE WEALTHY STE.
ARE OF SPECIAL INTEREST WATER
YOUR COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO TO.
THAT POINT THAT WAS BROUGHT UP.
RUNS AND SO WHAT POINT THAT WAS.
WHICH POINT I REFERRING TO WHAT
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD INDEED
VETOED.
I.
BUILT IT WAS A SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO THIS ONE AND THAT
DIED BY PROHIBITING
ORGANIZATIONS FROM SETTING
TARGETS QUOTAS.
FOR SIGNATURE GATHERERS ON
MAKING THE PRODUCTIVITY OF FOLKS
WHO ARE HELPING WITH THE
SIGNATURE DRIVE. UP THAT YOU'RE
AFFECTED LEE DRIVING UP THE COST
SO MUCH THAT ONLY THAT THE
WEALTHIEST OF SPECIAL INTERESTS
CAN INDEED ENGAGE AYE IN TRYING
TO QUALIFY A BALLOT MEASURE.
AS THE BILL.
IT IS WRITTEN THE THIS IS NOT
PROHIBITS PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS.
IT SIMPLY REDUCES THE.
RELIANCE ON SUCH A HOSTILE.
IN WHICH I HAVE OBSERVED WHEN I
WAS ATTRADER JOE'S IN WHICH IN
A SINGER GATHER SAID PLEASE SIGN
THIS PETITION.
AND THEN RIGHT BEHIND THAT ONE
PETITION THIS INDIVIDUAL ALSO
HAVE THREE OTHER PETITIONS FOR
OTHER OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
CHURCH TRIED TACKLE ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE INTEGRITY IN OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS.
THE COMMISSION CHAIR IF I COULD
REFLECT ON NOT THAT. EXPERIENCE
OF MANY OF MY PEERS ARE I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME FOLKS LIKE
TO CHARACTERIZE NOT PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERERS TO SAY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXCLUSIVELY
DURING THE SAYS THAT AS A
PROFESSION AYE BUT APART MY
EXPERIENCE I HIS BEEN THAT VERY
OFTEN FOLKS WHO WERE EMPLOYED.
AYE IS IS SIGNATURE GATHERERS IN
THIS MATTER A ARE OFTEN YOUNG
PEOPLE COLLEGE STUDENTS SECTOR
WHO WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
SPIN THE PUBLIC UP POLICY
PROCESS. UP BUT THIS IS INDEED
THE WAY OFFER THEM I TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT TO BE ABLE TO.
TO TO IMPORTANT THINGS EXCEPT
FOR.
I WOULD THINK THAT THIS. KIND OF
A BILL WOULD A SUBSTANTIALLY
GIVEN ADVANTAGE TO WELL MAYBE
EXISTING.
ONGOING POLITICAL ORGANIZATIONS
SIZE SUCH AS A LABOR UNION SIX
HATRA UP OR PEOPLE WHO WERE I
ABLE TO AFFORD A VERY EXTENSIVE
UP POLITICAL ONGOING NETWORK.
IS A SPECIAL INTERESTS
THEMSELVES AND I THINK THIS THIS
REDUCES OF THE GRASSROOTS
ASPECT.
OF SIGNATURE GATHERING.
I AND I LIKE.
WAS BROUGHT UP AS WELL I THINK
THAT THERE'S VERY SIGNIFICANT
FIRST AMENDMENT CONCERNS AND I
THINK IF THE SUB WOULD TO.
IF THIS WERE TO WHAT PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE AND BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WOULD BEACH PROBABLY STE BE
STRUCK DOWN ON FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME EXPRESS THOSE
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS HARPER.
IS WHAT MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A SECRET TO
ANYBODY IN THIS BUILDING THAT
THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH THE
INITIATIVE PROCESSAND AND AND
CALIFORNIA. IS DIRECT DEMOCRACY
OF THAT AT THE SAME TIME YOU
KNOW CONSTANTLY PASSES MEASURES
THAT TIES THE HANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
WHEN YOU'RE IF YOU ASK SOMEBODY
TO BUILD YOUR HOUSE.
AND YOU SEE HAVE TWO WEEKS TO DO
IT.
BEFORE WE LEAVE WE TO TIE ONE
HAND BEHIND YOUR BACK AND TAKE
AWAY ALL YOUR TOOLS TO DO IT.
HE TO BE PRETTY UNABLE TO BE
ABLE TO FIX THAT HOUSE TO BUILD
A HOUSE IN THE TIME FRAME AYE
LET ALONE DO IT ALL THAT
ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
A LOT OF TIMES DOES THE
LEGISLATION BEING ABLE TO DO OUR
JOB IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WHICH IS WHAT WE WERE ELECTED TO
DO. SO HAVE A LOT OF CONCERN
JUST IN GENERAL WITH THIS IDEA
OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY AND ITS
ACTUAL AFFECT ON DEMOCRACY IN
OUR ABILITY TO DO OUR JOBS
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
YOU KNOW TO SAY THAT THIS
MEASURE WOULD ONLY BECAUSE.
I'VE THIS PROCESS TO BE OPEN ARE
TO THE MOST WEALTHY OF PEOPLE TO
RUN INITIATIVES WELL THAT'S WHAT
IT IS NOW.
ALTHOUGH HOW MUCH MONEY DOES IT
TAKE TO ACTUALLY RUN A CAMPAIGN
TO GATHER FIVE HUNDRED PLUS
THOUSAND SIGNATURES
TAKES A LOT OF MONEY AND THE
SIGNATURE GATHERERS THEIR
DIFFERENT RATES OF WHICH THEY
CAN GET THEY CAN GET PAID THE
SUCCESS IS HOW MUCH MONEY YOU
HAVE TO BE ABLE. TO PUSH THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE ALL THE TIME FROM
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RUN INITIATIVES AND HAVE THE
MONEY TO DO IT AND AFFECTING
STATE POLICY TELLING OUR VOTERS
THIS IS GREAT FOR YOU. PASS THIS
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME IS GREW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY DON'T CARE THEY CARE ABOUT
THEIR BOTTOM DOLLAR THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT WHAT IT ACTUALLY. IS
THE FACT IN CALIFORNIA IN
WHITTIER I WANT TO TARGET.
THOSE THREATS RIGHT DOWN THE
STREET FROM OUR HOUSE.
SIGNATURE GATHERS OF COURSE
MULTIPLE PETITIONS TO SIGN RIGHT
THERE IN A BIG WHITE BOARD SAYS.
STOP THE LEGISLATURE FROM
RAISING YOUR TAXES REQUIRING
THEM TO HAVE A TWO THIRDS VOTE
PASS ANY TAX.
THAT LAW ALREADY EXISTS.
THAT'S A LIE.
BUT YET IT'S GREAT TALKING POINT
TRYING GATHER A SIGNATURE.
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER WE HAVE IN
THE SENATE ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
OR SOMEONE FROM OUTSIDE OF HIS
DISTRICT.
IT'S COMING IN.
PUSHING OF INITIATIVE ARE TO
HAVE A FOR RECALL THEY QUALIFIED
THAT RECALL AND AGAIN A LOT OF
THE CONCERNS FROM WHAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING. IS THAT.
REPEAL THE GAS TAX BUT
ESSENTIALLY WAS A.
IT NOT. OBVIOUSLY TO REPEAL THE
GAS TAX IT WAS TO SIGN A
PETITION TO CALL FOR RECALL ON
THE SEA SENATOR.
AND SO. YOU KNOW I I.
IT AN AND AGAIN YOU KNOW JUST
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR VETOED THE
BILL DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT A
GOOD IDEA TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
AN ISSUE LIKE THIS HOUSE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN IT SEVEN YEARS
AGO.
I RAN THE SAME BILL TWO YEARS IN
A ROW FOR YOUR GOT AT A VETO. ON
RIGHT TO TRY THE SECOND YEAR YOU
SIGNED IT SO ARE AND I THINK THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH THE GOVERNOR
VETOED THE BILL THE FIRST TIME
AROUND VERSUS THE CIRCUMSTANCES
TODAY WHAT WE ARE SEEING MORE
ISSUES WITH THE.
WITH THE INITIATIVE PROCESS AND
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING INTO
OUR STATE OR THAT ARE ALREADY IN
OUR STATE WE THINK ABOUT THE
HOUSING ISSUES AND THE END OF IN
THE INITIATIVES ARE BEING PUSHED
BY INDIVIDUALS IN THE LA COUNTY.
TO KEEP THEIR VIEW FROM BEING
BLOCKING SOLIS THAT'S THAT'S BUT
RUN A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE I'M
MILLIONAIRE I GOT A LINE MONEY
SO I DON'T WANT MY VIEW
OBSTRUCTED SOMEONE WHY PASS
INITIATIVES THAT YOU CAN BUILD
ANYTHING YET WE HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE. HOUSING CRISIS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WAS
THEY GOT DEFEATED.
BUT STILL QUALIFY BECAUSE HE
HAD THE MONEY TO GET THE
SIGNATURE SO THERE'S A REALLY
BIG ISSUE NO HUGE DISCONNECT.
ARE AND WHEN YOU WHEN YOU ARE
YOU KNOW SIGNATURE FARMING AND
YOU'RE GETTING PAID PER
SIGNATURE THERE'S THAT. THERE'S
AN AUTOMATIC A DESIRE TO GET AS
MANY SIGNATURES.
HOWEVER YOU POSSIBLY CAN BECAUSE
THAT'S ARE GETTING PIC IS I
AGREE WITH THE VICE CHAIR
STATEMENT. THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE DOING THIS BECAUSE THEY NEED
THE MONEY AND I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH THAT AND I THINK THERE'S
NOBODY BETTER MONEY TO TAKING
ESPECIALLY HELP YOU SURVIVE IN
THIS KIND OF MONEY.
BUT.
I THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT THAT'S THE BEST THAT'S THE
BEST POLICY THE BEST PRACTICE.
FOR.
DEMOCRACY AND THIS KIND OF
DIVIDE DIRECT DEMOCRACY THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS AND SAVE
CALIFORNIA. SO YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT THE THE AUTHOR UNDERSTANDS
THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S MORE WORK
BUT HE'S GONNA BE DOING ON THIS
BILL AND I THINK IT WOULD BE A
DISSERVICE.
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS BILLS TENURE RIGHT HERE
IT'S TO KEEP IT GOING ON CITY
KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING AND
I AND I FULLY EXPECT THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION A
CALVET HIM COMMERCE THING GIVES
IN THE CONVERSATION. ARE BECAUSE
THEY WERE ALL CALIFORNIANS
WE REALLY NEED TO BE MORE ON THE
SAME PAGE ARE NOT JUST IN THIS
STATE. ABA NATIONALLY
IT'S ALL FOR THE GREATER GOOD
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO TAKE MORE
CONTROL OVER WHO HAS THE MONEY
AND IS PUTTING.
ADMISSION IS ON THE BALLOT THAT
ARE AFFECTING EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF US SO.
AND MOVE THE BILL IN TO BE
VOTING YES AND THANK YOU MR
LAFFER BRING THE BILL FOR. THE
MISTER CALDERON.
MS BUT.
IS WEBER YEAH RIVER THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD OBVIOUSLY SPARKED QUITE
A BIT OF CONVERSATION.
AND I WILL PROBABLY VOTE TO
MOVE BEFORE BUT NO GUARANTEE
THAT APPLE FOR ON THE FLOOR.
MY CONCERN IS THAT MUCH OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT EVERYONE IS REYES
IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN TERMS
OF THE FLAWS OF OUR. OUR OUR
SYSTEM ITSELF THE PETITIONS THE
THE ISSUES OF PEOPLE NOT TELLING
THE TRUTH SOME FOLKS HAVE
SEVERAL. OF PETITIONS AND I'VE
BEEN THERE TO SEE THE MALL WITH
A ROLL THEM OUT TO YOU AND I
DON'T DO THEM.
AND THERE'S ALWAYS THERE'S A
LOT OF THAT I'M NOT SURE OF THIS
BILL SOLVES THAT PROBLEM THAT'S
MY CONCERN IS THAT IF I WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT THE FLAWS IN THE
IN THE WHOLE SYSTEM OF
PETITIONS.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I'M
NOT SURE IF IF IF SAYING YOU
CAN'T BE INCENTIVIZE TO COLLECT
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF.
SIGNATURES YOU GET.
BUT WE CAN PAY BY THE HOUR TO
DO IT.
I AM NOT SURE IF IF THAT SOLVES
MY PROBLEM.
BECAUSE IF THE PETITION THE
SITUATION STILL EXISTS PROBABLY
THOSE WHO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PAY PEOPLE BY THE HOUR. A WHICH
IS QUITE A BIT OF MONEY.
WOULD PROBABLY DO THAT.
AND WOOD STILL IN THAT WITH ALL
THESE THINGS TAKING PLACE ALL
YOU HIRE PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT IT BECAUSE WHY
YOU PAYING ABOUT OUR MEGA
COMPETE TO BE THE PERSON THAT
YOU PAY BY THE HOUR. WHO MAKES
IS A DECENT SALARY ARE
COLLECTING SIGNATURES SO I'M NOT
SURE THE SOLVE ANY OF THOSE
PROBLEMS?
ARE THEY MAY EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM WITH ANYTHING.
BUT AND AND IT DOESN'T ADDRESS
AT ALL ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PETITION PROCESS
SOME INTEGRITY IN THE PETITIONS
OUT OF THE YEAR HOW THEY'RE
ADVERTISED TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
THE NOT THERE'S. NO THEY HAVE TO
BE TRUTHFUL ABOUT IT THEY CAN
MAYBE ONLY CURE ONE PETITION
WHATEVER IT IS BUT I'M NOT SURE
IF THIS SOLVES THE PROBLEM IT IT
IT MAKES US FEEL BETTER. A BUT
IT MAY MAKE THE WHOLE PROCESS
BECOME MORE OF DIFFICULT AND AND
NOT NECESSARILY VERY EFFECTIVE
OF THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE WHOLE
IDEA. OF THE OF THE CITIZEN
PETITION WITHIN THAT THAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO AND
WHERE IT AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD EXIST. AND
MAYBE THERE MAY BE MORE
RESTRICTIONS OR SOMETHING PLACED
ON THOSE WHO COME UP WITH WITH
WITH THESE PETITIONS AND HOW
THEY MARKETED IN ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
BUT I'M NOT SURE OF THE SOLVE
ANY OF THOSE PROBLEMS I THINK IT
IT IT IT IT IT APPROACHES IT BUT
IT REALLY DOESN'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE PEOPLE GENERALLY
FIND A WAY AROUND IT. AND I
THINK MOST FOLKS ARE SAYING THAT
THAT THIS PROCESS WHILE IT HAD
SOME INITIAL VALUE IN TERMS OF
HELPING THE CITIZENS HAVE
ENGAGEMENT.
ANIME ALSO CALL AND IT AND THE
PETITION PROCESS IS CALLED MANY
PEOPLE NOT TO BE AS ENGAGED AS A
SHOULD AS VOTERS IN TERMS OF
VOTING FOLKS OUT OF OFFICE. WE
DON'T THINK OF DOING A VERY GOOD
JOB.
THEY HAVE A TENDENCY ONE RIGHT
THE LAWS THEMSELVES WHICH
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE A LOT MORE
COMPLICATIONS THAN ANYTHING ELSE
AND MOST OF THEM INTO BEING
LITIGATED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
BECAUSE A POORLY WRITTEN.
BUT I'M GONNA AYE I THINK THE
CONVERSATION SHOULD GO FORWARD.
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS.
READY FOR PRIMETIME IN TERMS OF
REALLY ANSWERED THE QUESTIONS OF
THIS WHOLE PROCESS OF THE OF THE
INITIATIVE BUT ALL SUPPORT IT
NOW WITH THE HOPES OF FINDING
THAT THERE'S A LOT MORE THAN
THAT YOU GOING TO DO WITH THIS.
THEN SIMPLY DO THIS RESTRICTION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
ANY ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOOKING FOR A
SECOND. ON THE MOTION FOR MISTER
CALDERON.
GIVE US TWO SECONDS THAT'S GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO.
WOULD YOU LIKE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE INSULA AT YOU YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS AND
TO SOME OF OUR WEBER. OF THE
THEY RECOGNITION OF THAT.
WHEN
TALKING AND CHALLENGING THAT
PETITION GATHER.
IF THEY KNOW THAT YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO SIGN OR THAT YOUR
CHALLENGE THEM ON THIS ISSUE.
TO WHICH I COUNT THEM THIS OKAY
WILL JUST I'M NOT GONNA TALK TO
ANYMORE AND THEY'RE GONNA GO
TELL THE PERSON BECAUSE THEY'RE
SO FOCUSED ON GETTING THAT
SIGNATURE BECAUSE OF. THE
INCENTIVE THERE WHEREAS IF
THEY'RE PAID HOURLY THEN OR SPY
STIPEND OR WHATEVER THE NOTION
MIGHT BE THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
TO TALK TO YOU AND. TRY TO
CONVINCE YOU ON THESE ISSUES
WHETHER INCENTIVIZE BY SAYING
OKAY BLAH I'M JUST GOING TO HAVE
NOT EVEN PAY ATTENTION TO YOU
BECAUSE. YOU NOT WORTH MY TIME
I'M NOT GONNA TRY TO CONVINCE
YOU WHERE SOMEONE SPENT SOMETIME
TO GETTING SOME OTHER. AND
INDUBITABLE NO OTHER PERSON IN
DECEIVING AND AND DIFFERENT WAY.
AND SO THAT THAT'S WHY I THINK
THAT THERE'S THAT THE
DISTINCTION AND THE NUANCE
BETWEEN THAT OF NOT
INCENTIVIZING. A AND USING IT BY
EACH SIGNATURE AND THAT HUSTLE
UP BECAUSE JUST AS MISTER
CALDERON MENTIONED THAT IT WAS
MY EXPERIENCE SIMILARLY OUT WITH
THAT EXPERIENCE. AND THE
PETITION GATHER NOT BEING
FACTUAL NOT SPENDING THE TIME
NECESSARY TO ENGAGE IN A
THOUGHTFUL DIALOG TO WHICH THE
PERSON EVEN SAID BUT WHAT WOULD
YOU KNOW.
BUT DID YOU KNOW YOU WEREN'T
THERE WHEN ON THIS S. B. ONE
VOTE.
.
AND OF COURSE IT I JUST KIND OF
LAUGHED AND SAID OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I STEPPED AWAY.
AND WATCH THIS PERSON ENGAGE IN
A COSTING.
OTHER PEOPLE. A AND MISTER
BERMAN'S DISTRICT AT THIS
STORE. AND SAW THE SAME TYPE OF
ACTIVITY.
SO.
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
POSSIBILITIES TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONVERSATIONS ON MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS IN
WITH RESPECT TO A DIRECT ROUTE
DEMOCRACY.
BOB THIS IS JUST ONE
SUBMIT.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
REVIVAL.
THANK YOU MR LOW END AND THANK
YOU FOR.
DOING BUSINESS IN MY DISTRICT.
WHICH I APPRECIATE.
BUT AS I THINK IT'S BEEN A
GREAT CONVERSATION.
AND A LOT OF REALLY GOOD POINTS.
THE.
CLEARLY ARE DIRECT DEMOCRACY
SYSTEM ARE INITIATIVE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN CORRUPTED FROM ITS ORIGINAL
INTENT. OF ALLOWING THAT PEOPLE
TO GET AROUND IT SPECIAL MONEYED
INTERESTS OUGHT TO HAVE A SAY.
IN IN DEMOCRACY IN OUR
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND AND
NOW IT'S ONLY THE WEALTHY THAT
CAN AFFORD TO UTILIZE A DIRECT
DEMOCRACY SYSTEM.
BUT TO GET THE VOTES THEY NEED
AND.
I THINK ALL OF US HAVE PROBABLY
SEEN WHAT MR LOW DESCRIBED.
IN TERMS OF.
LIKE IT CHARACTERIZES THE
HUSTLE.
OF THE SIGNATURE GATHERERS THAT
HAVE A HALF DOZEN OR MORE
DIFFERENT PETITIONS.
DO YOU KNOW IF YOU POKE DEBATE
ALL THEY DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO GET
SIGNATURES FOR.
AND CLEARLY THEY'RE USING
TALKING POINTS THAT THEY FOUND.
I GET THEM.
MOST SIGNATURE IS THE FASTEST
NOT NECESSARILY TALKING POINTS
THAT ACTUALLY ACCURATELY PORTRAY
WHAT THE INITIATIVE WOULD DO.
AND AND SO WE NEED TO FILE AS
AS A DOCTOR WEBER SAID YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM.
ARE ON THE WHOLE I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I KNOW THAT.
SOME ISSUES WERE RAISED AROUND
THE LEGALITY OF IT AND I REALLY
WANT ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO READ
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
FOR THIS BILL IT TOOK ME BACK TO
LAW SCHOOL.
AND I WANT TO TO COMMEND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR ANALYSIS OF
BUT IT CLEARLY SHOWS THAT
INFINITE IN FEBRUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND SIX THE NINTH CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS. RULED THAT AN
ORGAN LAW THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR
TO THIS LOT TODAY.
THAT PROHIBITED PAYMENT
ELECTORAL PETITION SIGNATURE
GATHERERS.
DID NOT IMPOSE A SEVERE BURDEN
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
AND SO I COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
FOR FOLLOWING.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT LAW WAS.
QUITE CLOSELY I'M VERY
CONFIDENT THAT THIS WOULD BE UP
HELD BY THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT
OF APPEALS IT'S ALSO BEEN UPHELD
BY MULTIPLE OTHER COURTS OF
APPEALS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
SO I'M OF TOTALLY GONE OFF
SCRIPT OF MY TALKING POINTS.
BUT LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF MEASURES
CAN BE HELD LIABLE FOR
ENCOURAGING MISCONDUCT BY THE
PETITION CIRCULATORS. THE
EMPLOYEE AND I THINK THIS BILL
IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD
IMPROVING THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND RECALL
PROCESS ON RECOMMENDING SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL LOCAL VOTE AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE AYE.
BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER NOW CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW AYE LOW AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PATTERSON.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SO THAT'S OUT ON THE FIVE ONE
VOTE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
LOWE WOULD LIKE TO. PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
THE CHAIR MEMBERS YOU'VE SEEN
THIS BILL BEFORE. ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY.
WE SAW A A HISTORIC LOW VOTER
TURNOUT OF JUST TWENTY FIVE.
PERCENT OF REGISTERED VOTERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN PRIMARY.
.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY FOURTEEN
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE ELECTION
DAY AS A HOLIDAY. AND THE INTENT
OF THIS IS TO.
REMOVE AS MANY PERRANCE AS
POSSIBLE TO PARTICIPATION.
AND WITH ME AND SUPPORT IS BY
INGRAM WITH THE ACLU.
THANK.
I INGRAM LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE PLEASE TEAR TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT REMOVES
BARRIERS TO VOTING.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BE
PLAGUED BY LOW ELECTION TURNOUT
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ACCORDING TO
THE U. S. CENSUS CALIFORNIA
RANKED FORTY FIRST AND ELIGIBLE
VOTERS TURNING OUT AT THE POLLS.
THIS.
TURNOUT DISPARITY IS
PARTICULARLY NOTICEABLE ALONG
INCOME LINES ACCORDING TO THE US
CENSUS ONLY HALF OF ELIGIBLE
VOTERS WITH AN INCOME HOUSEHOLD
OF TWENTY THOUSAND OR LESS VOTED
IN TWENTY TWELVE. AND ONLY
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT VOTED IN THE
TWENTY TEN MID TERMS
THIS IS IN CONTRAST WITH
HOUSEHOLDS OF. HOUSEHOLD INCOMES
OF OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THEY TURNED OUT AT RATES
OF EIGHTY AND SIXTY PERCENT
RESPECTIVELY.
THIS HELPS REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
LOW INCOME VOTERS WHO OFTEN CITE
WORK AND SCHOOL CONFLICTS AS THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR NOT VOTING.
WHILE STATE LAW DOES ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE TWO HOURS
OFF IN ORDER TO VOTE THIS TIME
OFF IS OFTEN GIVEN AT THE
BEGINNING OR END OF THE SHIFT.
WHICH ALSO COINCIDES WITH THE
LONGEST LINES OFTEN AT POLLING
PLACES
OBSERVING A STATE HOLIDAY WOULD
HELP GET PEOPLE OUT TO VOTE AND
WE HOPE CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN THE
SIXTEEN OTHER STATES AND THE
TERRITORY OF PORTO RICO AND
ENACTING. SUCH A REFORM
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MORNING RAIN CITY
WHEREVER ON THE PACIFIC A PART
OF CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR. OF THIS IS BEEN
OF ONE OF THE PARTS OF OUR
PLATFORM FOR ALMOST FIFTY YEARS
SO. BETTER COME AND SUPPORTED
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
JOHN RIEGER SECRETARY. OF STATE
CENTRAL COMMITTEE FOR PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY IN URGING YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
MR ROBERT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ON CENTRAL POINT ON THIS IS THAT
ITSELF ONLY FOR GOVERNING POLICE
ON MY UNDERSTANDING OF STATE
EMPLOYEES CITY EMPLOYEES SCHOOL
DISTRICT SPECIAL DISTRICT SITE
COUNTY SIX ATRA.
.
LIKE ALL EMPLOYEES
OUR ART VIS EMPLOYEES ABLE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE OFF TIME ON
ELECTION DAY AS PER STATE LAW.
TO BE ABLE TO VOTE ALREADY.
BUT AND NOT THE ENTIRE DAY.
THE ENTIRE DAY NOT.
THE IS IS THE ASSERTION THAT IT
WOULD TAKE THE ENTIRE DAY TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE RENTS IN.
THE CALL.
THE QUESTION THAT YOU'RE ASKING
THEM.
IS INSINUATING THAT.
THERE IS AMPLE TIME THAT IS
CURRENTLY PROVIDED TO
PARTICIPATE IN ELECTIONS.
WHICH PREVENT DISPUTE THE NEED
INTENT OF JOINING FOURTEEN OTHER
STATES IN MAKING ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY.
PART.
ARE THERE EXAMPLES THERE CITED
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
GIVEN THE TIME OFF TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE WERE GOVERNMENT PLOY.
SURE.
IS I DON'T SEE THAT THE
BACKGROUND.
OKAY.
I IT.
IF WE HAVE OUR WE WE'VE
CONVERTED A LOT OF OUR.
.
ELECTIONS TO VOTE BY MAIL.
DOES THIS KICK AND IF THIS IS
ALL VOTE BY MAIL ELECTION.
THIS.
FUNDAMENTALLY.
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW
FOR US TO. LOWER THE BARRIERS OF
ENTRY AND PARTICIPATION.
AND.
OR NO VOTE IN THE PAST INDICATES
THAT.
PERHAPS YOU
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS AMPLE.
MATERNITY TO PARTICIPATE WHETHER
IT BE VOTE BY MAIL WHETHER MP
THREE LIMITED HOURS. BUT NOT
EVERYONE FITS WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME.
DOESN'T WORK FOR EVERYONE.
SO WHY WOULD WE NOT WANT TO.
LOWER AS MANY BEERS TO ENTRY.
THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
WAS IT POINTED OUT IN EVERY
ELECTION NOT JUST LECTURES THERE
BICKLEY VOTE BY MAIL UP IN EVERY
ELECTION ANYONE CAN BE A VOTE BY
MAIL VOTER.
AND DOT YOUR PERMANENT VOTE BY
MAIL VOTER AYE THERE'S IN FACT A
FOUR WEEK PERIOD WHEN THEY START
MAILING OUT THOSE PERMANENT
ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
I TO BE ABLE TO CAST A BALLOT
AND WE'VE ALSO LEGALIZE THE
SITUATION WHICH
I PEOPLE CAN DROP OFF THAT
BALLOT IN THE MAIL.
YOU'LL BE YOU'LL BE COUNTED IF
IT'S RECEIVED BY THE REGISTRAR
VOTERS AFTER ELECTION DAY. AS
LONG AS IT'S POSTMARKED ON A BY
ELECTION DAY AYE YOU ALSO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THE BALLOT CAN
BE BALLOT HARVESTED.
IT BE TAKEN BY SOMEONE WHO'S NOT
EVEN A FAMILY MEMBER TO THE
BALLOT BOX TO THE RIGHT FOR
VOTERS SIX ATRA. AYE YOU ALSO
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE.
BELT CAN BE DROPPED OFF ON
ELECTION DAY.
NOT TAKING THE SIGNUP AMOUNT OF
TIME.
THE THING I THINK IS IMPORTANT
BE ABLE ASK.
IS WHAT WAS THE FIGURE YOU SAID.
THAT WAS VOTER PARTICIPATION FOR
THE PRIMARY TWENTY FOURTEEN.
THE ANSWER I'M GOING TO GIVE IS
THAT IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
ISSUES THAT YOU DECIDED AND WE
ALSO WANNA MAKE ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY. TO MAKE IT THAT MUCH
EASIER
SO THEY DON'T SUPPORT THIS THEN
YOU BUT I'D LIKE TO INCREASE
HIGHER NOT TO ENTRY IN THAT IS
OKAY. LOOK THE QUESTION I HAD IS
THAT YOU CITED A FIGURE.
AND I DID NOT CATCH THAT THAT
WAS THE VOTER PROSPECT
PARTICIPATION RATE CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE PRIMARY IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN HE OPENED WITH IT YES.
WHAT WAS THE PERCENTAGE?
THEN TWENTY FIVE PERCENT IN THE
PRIMARY TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
SO.
IT WAS TWENTY FIVE PERCENT THE
PRIMER TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND MISTREAT YOU PERCENT OF
REGISTERED VOTERS PARTICIPATING
THAT AND THAT WAS A FORTY TWO
PERCENT IN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD THINK YOU'D
BE VERY IMPORTANT.
UPDATE THE COMMITTEE THAT IN
TWENTY FOUR BY SIXTEEN.
THE VOTER RATE HAD INDEED
SKYROCKETED.
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE VOTER
PARTICIPATION RATE HAS FAR MORE
TO DO WITH VOTERS INTEREST IN
VOTING FOR CANDIDATE AGAINST A
CANDIDATE FOR A BALLOT
INITIATIVE AGAINST THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE.
BASED UPON THEIR INFORMATION ON
WHAT THEY FEEL QUALIFIES HIM TO
BE A VOTER IN A PARTICULAR
ELECTION RATHER THAN ANY
BARRIERS BECAUSE AS I POINTED
OUT.
IF SOMEONE WANTS TO VOTE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY CAN VOTE OVER THE COURSE OF
FOUR WEEKS WITH A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT. THEY CAN HAVE THEIR
BALLOT TAKEN TO THE POLLING
PLACE THEY CAN TAKE THEIR BALLOT
TO THE POLLING PLACE
THEY CAN PUT IT IN THE MAIL.
THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY IN THE
STATE.
ARE NOT SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH.
BE ABLE TO BE GIVING A PAID
HOLIDAY.
TALL GOVERNMENT PLEASE.
EXCLUSIVELY.
AND GIVING A PARTICULAR VANTAGE
TWO ONE SET OF VOTERS.
TO OTHERS.
BUT I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE MANY
WAYS.
PEOPLE CAN ALREADY CAST A BALLOT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
MANY OF THOSE REFORMS INDEED
PASSED IN A BIPARTISAN BASIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MY
COMPASS MIXTURE THAT YOU MISS
HARPER.
CALDERON THANK YOU.
MISTRESS WAS CLEAR THAT THE
BILL IS A GOOD MAKES THE FIRST
USING AT THE FIRST MONDAY
NOVEMBER OF EACH EVEN NUMBERED
YEAR STATE HOLIDAY SO WOULD BE
TO THE AYE. AYE WELL I
UNDERSTAND THE POINT THAT THE
VICE CHAIR IS MAKING I JUST
DON'T SEE A REALITY WHERE WE
REALLY END UP WITH A HUNDRED
PERCENT ALL MALE. VOTE BY MAIL
ELECTIONS YOU HAVE INDIVIDUALS
LIKE MYSELF I ACT LIKE A SOAP
POLLS ABOUT MYSELF. I HAVE
ALWAYS DONE THAT AND I I THINK I
WILL ALWAYS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK IS PART
OF PART PART OF THE THRILL.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE
THE THE IDEA OF OR THE ISSUE
BEING RAISED THAT THE VOTER
REGISTRATION BE I MEAN THE VOTER
TURNOUT BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN IS BECAUSE OF A
LOT OF THE MEASURES THAT WE PASS
INCREASED ACCESS.
I TO VOTING AND AND AND AND MAKE
IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE I
NAY REYES THOSE TYPES OF.
DE TO TO PASS THOSE ISSUES AIR
AND CREATE MORE OF US OUT OF OUR
A HOSPITABLE SITUATION IN WHICH
PEOPLE CAN CAN FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR CAST
ABOUT HOW THEIR VOICE.
HEARD.
SO I MEAN I I I I AND I ALSO
THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW THERE THERE THERE THERE
IS WISDOM.
IN AND HOW YOU'RE APPROACHING
THIS ISSUE SPECIFICALLY LIMITED
LIMITING IT TO ARM YOU KNOW
STATE EMPLOYEES ARE BECAUSE
THERE WOULD BE AN IMPACT THAT I
DON'T THINK I I MEAN I THINK WE
WOULD SEE THE CAL CHAMBER UP
HERE.
AGAIN IF WE SAID OKAY FOR
EVERYBODY EVEN INCLUDING IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ARE YOU HAVE TO
PAY A BUSINESS.
PAID HOLIDAY
FOR YOUR EMPLOYEES TO GO AND
VOTE ON ELECTION DAY ARE I WOULD
I PREFER I WOULD PREFER THAT.
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
WOULD BE AN IMPACT ON BUSINESS
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THE. THAT
ANYBODY ESPECIALLY MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE THE AISLE
WOULD ABS WOULD ACTUALLY NOT BE
SUPPORTIVE OF SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I'M SURE THEY WOULDN'T HAPPY TO
DO IT IF IT WAS WITHOUT PAY
I BUT I UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT.
TO BUSINESSES IF.
IS A PAID HOLIDAY.
AND AND AGAIN.
YOU KNOW THERE'S JUST BEEN NO
EMPHASIS
FOR MY GENERATION IS NEXT
GENERATION ON VOTING AND WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FIRST THEY
DON'T SEE GOVERNMENT AS AN
EFFECTIVE PLACE TO CREATE CHANGE
BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT. ONE
PARTY IN ANOTHER PARTY FIGHTING
EACH OTHER BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S
JUST THE WAY IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
I'M RIGHT YOU'RE WRONG AND
THAT'S THAT THAT'S GOVERNMENT.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
EMPHASIS AND VALUE PLACED IN
THIS DAY AS AN ELECTION DAY
HOUSE THAT THERE HAS TO BE MORE
IMPORTANT SOMETHING THAT TAKES
ATTENTION.
OF THESE YONG INDIVIDUALS TO
SAY YET IT'S A HOLIDAY BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT.
EVERY A LOT OF THESE IMPORTANT
DAYS WE CELEBRATED HOLIDAYS
BECAUSE OF THEIR SIGNIFICANCE
AND I THINK THAT I'M STARTING AT
LEAST WITH OUR STATE EMPLOYEES.
YOU YOU YOU RE EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BEING A
SIGNIFICANT DAY TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
A FUNDAMENTAL PILLAR OF OUR
DEMOCRACY AND THE FACT THAT A
WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE OR A WHOLE
LOT OF CENTURIES AND ARE DECADES
HAVE FOUGHT. AND CONTINUE TO
FIGHT TODAY.
DEBT DEBT TO ALLOW US THIS RIGHT
TO VOTE SO I THINK THAT ARE IT'S
AN AND YOU KNOW IT IT'S
SOMETHING SMALL.
DOT I DON'T THINK YOU KNOW THE
STATE LOSES ANYTHING.
BECAUSE IF WE WOULD OF ALREADY
BEEN PAYING FOR THAT DAY
ANYWAYS.
IF THEY WERE TO WORK OUT BUT I
THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT FOR AT
LEAST GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES TO.
NET THAT THEIR WORK THAT THEY
DON'T DO IS ALREADY IMPORTANT IT
IS IMPORTANT IS NEEDED BUT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THEY SHOP AND
REGISTER THAT. THAT VOTE AND
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY WE CAN MOVE TO
IT BEING ALSO AFFORDED TO
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS BUT I
APPRECIATE THE BILL. I'M GONNA
VOTE YES AND I'M OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON WAS
MULLIN.
I THINK MISS SHARON AND.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN FOR
BRINGING THE BILL I THINK IT IS
A STATEMENT OF.
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF ELECTION
DAY AND.
THE IMPORTANCE OF DEMOCRACY.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA UP TO
THE VICE CHAIRS POINT I DO THINK
WE ARE. TO SOME DEGREE DE
EMPHASIZING ELECTION DAY ITSELF
BECAUSE WE HAVE.
OF THE SP FOUR FIFTY ERA UPON
US WHERE MORE AND MORE COUNTIES
WILL BE MOVING TO AN ALL MAIL
BALLOT.
ALL ELECTION SO I SORT OF
CONSIDER ELECTION DATA BE ALMOST
LIKE ELECTION MONTH BECAUSE
THERE IS SO MUCH ACTIVITY WITH
VOTING BY MAIL. AND I THINK THAT
TREND IS IS PRETTY CLEAR BUT I
THINK IT'S STILL. CRUCIAL TO TO
STATE THE IMPORTANCE OF ELECTION
DAY ITSELF BECAUSE EVEN IN THE
ALL MAIL BALLOT.
A COUNTIES LIKE MINE SAN MATEO
COUNTY. THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF
ACTIVITY ON ELECTION DAY ITSELF
THERE ARE HIGH TECH VOTING
CENTERS.
SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY AYE IN EACH COMMUNITY
WITH PAUL BOOKS AND A BALLOT
PRINTING ACTIVITY IN THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF. ACTION ON
ELECTION DAY ITSELF EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE GOING TO BE AN ALL MAIL
BALLOT A COUNTY SO OUGHT TO THAT
EXTENT I SUPPORT THE EFFORT I
KNOW THIS IS AN ONGOING ONE. LAW
THAT HAS NOT MADE IT OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS A HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL CHANGE THIS YEAR. LA IF THE
BILL'S NOT BEEN MOVED ALL DO SO.
OR AT LEAST A SECOND THE BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR THE EFFORT.
FITNESS MULLIN SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND AYE MR MULLIN. DOCTOR
WEBER. QUICK QUESTION.
.
IN THE A STAFF REPORT. AND MAYBE
OF OTHER INFORMATION OTHER
THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN OF.
BASICALLY SAYING THAT IN THE
STATES I GUESS WHAT THEY'RE
SIXTEEN STATE SOMETHING I DON'T
KNOW FOURTEEN WHAT THINGS ARE
DATES THAT HAVE ACTUALLY DONE
THIS. THAT THERE'S BEEN NO.
INCREASE IN VOTER PARTICIPATION
AS A RESULT OF MAKING A HOLIDAY.
WHAT WOULD WE DO DIFFERENT AS
AS?
AS A STATE THAT WOULD BASICALLY
DRIVE FOLKS TO THE POLL.
I KNOW WE'RE DOING ALL THESE
THINGS AT A MONTH LONG LEAD WITH
IT IS BEFORE FIFTIES LIVE OF
EVERYTHING. OF WHAT DO WE DO TO
TO WARRANT THIS HOLIDAY OF THIS
DAY OFF THAT WOULD MAKE IT.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT SINCE OF THE
STATE DONE IT HAVE SEEN NO
INCREASE IN PARTICIPATION AT
ALL.
QUOTE BY A PART OF THE.
IT IS FOR THIS ALSO WAS THERE A
PEW RESEARCH STUDY THAT FOUND
THAT SCHOOL WORK WAS ONE OF THE
ATTRIBUTED FACTORS OF
PARTICIPATION AND SO THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
CITE. ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL A
STUDIES I'M WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL TO
IDENTIFY THOSE SPECIFICS UP BUT
AGAIN THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION IS NOT ONLY. ON
DRIVING OUT PARTICIPATION BUT
THE FUNDAMENTALS OF WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD FROM FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH IS OUR CIVIC DUTIES
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT.
AND SCHOOLS WOULD BE CLOSED.
IS THAT CORRECT.
WILK WILL WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
STATE EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYEES NO
NO NO THE LOCALS OKAY BECAUSE I
WAS SEEING SOMETHING THEM SEE IT
CA BECAUSE ADMINISTER.
SCHOOLS THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF
ASSOCIATION AND AND.
AS THEY WERE SUPPORTING IT SO
THEY WOULD NOT BE AFFECTED THEM
THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
MEDINA. OH OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR LOAD YOUR
TO CLOSE.
A THE.
THAT THE THAT THE FOCUS AGAIN ON
SERVE OUR CIVICS.
AND OUR PARTICIPATION.
IS A CRUCIAL ONE AT JUST AS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OF. CESAR CHAVEZ
DAY.
OR AND OKAYED A THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PARENTS TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
MEANING OF THIS
IT IS IS IMPORTANT. AND SO IN
ADDITION TO THAT OF THE INTENT
OF THE FUNDAMENTALS OF DRIVING
THAT PARTICIPATION IN LAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND SO.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE.
A LOT OF GOOD POINTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TODAY I SUPPORTED.
AN IDENTICAL BILL BY YOU LAST
YEAR AND I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
ON YOUR COMMITMENT TO TAKING
STEPS TO MAKE. OUR ELECTIONS
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO VOTERS AND
WITH THAT I HAVE RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE. ADAM SECRETARY WE CALL
VOTE.
IF THE MOTION IS TO PASS IN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION BERMAN
AYE.
BERMAN I HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW AYE LOW AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN AYE PATTERSON.
WEBER AYE WEBER AYE.
THAT'S AT ON A FIVE ONE VOTE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO.
MISTER MULLIN.
TO MEN SECRETARY I CAN YOU.
.
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE BILLS OF
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WHO ARE NOW
HERE I AM. MISTER MULLIN ON AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX CARILLO.
MULLIN I
.
RIGHT TO.
YEAH.
I HOPE IT WILL.
NOW.
BOTH ERIC.
SO IN WITH THAT THE HEARINGS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU